Pour avoir plus de pouvoir, on a décidé de marier Clarisse.
A un riche noble et puissant.
Le problème c'est que son futur époux arrive aujourd'hui.
Et que je sais absolument pas comment organiser ce mariage.
Donc on y va...
Tempête d'idées !
Une cérémonie religieuse.
Éviter une tuerie au moment du gâteau.
Oh putain, il faut un gâteau...
Commencer déjà par me demander mon avis ?
Est-ce que je peux choisir mon mari ?
Je voudrais épouser l'homme que j'aime.
Bonjour monsieur, vous avez un très très beau cheval.
Ah pas du tout, ça a rien à voir, c'est une chaise.
Et oh, oh, sérieux !
Trouver un gâteau ça me stresse là.
C'est totalement dégueulasse.
On m'impose un mari et j'ai rien le droit de dire parce que je suis une femme !
Bah...
C'est une blague ?
Non.
En tant que seigneur j'ai le droit d'ordonner ce mariage.
Par contre, pour le gâteau...
Je sais vraiment pas comment faire.
On pourrait peut-être faire plusieurs tartes !
Comme ça y a un panel.
Le dernier mariage du Royaume s'est très mal passé.
Et quand je dis "très mal passé", je parle pas d'une intoxication alimentaire.
C'était un bain de sang !
Plantage de femme enceinte...
Flèches dans les yeux, arrachage de gorge...
Non, on va essayer de faire un truc un peu plus festif.
Et donc, les mystères sont de mise.
Ah...
Alors !
Voici Aelys.
Notre maître d'arme.
Bonjour.
Réflexe !
C'est le meilleur !
Voici Yorel, notre mestre.
Ah le mestre c'est un genre de moine chez vous, c'est ça ?
Ouais.
D'accord...
Qu'est ce qu'il y a ?
Non, je... rien... enfin...
Si y a un truc.
- Si, si, si.
Enfin vous avez un guerrier, vous avez...
Vous avez un moine, vous avez un château...
Une armure et tout, c'est...
Bah quoi ? Qu'est ce qu'y a ? Je vais pas foutre un ficus.
Euh... non.
Euh... c'est juste comme chez moi.
Non.
Ah bah si, je suis désolé hein mais ça ressemble tellement.
D'ailleurs, on se connaîtrait pas...
Je me dis "bon, il a un peu imité le style".
Non, je vous jure que non, quand même pas.
Ah bah lui là, j'ai exactement le même.
En maigre.
Allez, venez.
Oh mais dès qu'il y a des pierres et des armures ça se ressemble.
Et enfin...
Voici Clarisse.
Bonjour.
Ça va ?
Bon.
Très bien.
Et mon épouse elle est où ?
Votre épouse c'est Clarisse.
Mon épouse c'est ?
Salutation.
Ok.
C'est bon.
Me marier de force à un seigneur que je découvre à peine.
Je trouve ça outrageant.
Et inhumain...
Mais comme c'est pour l'honneur de la maison, je me résigne.
Il est chou.
Dès que je l'ai vu, le temps s'est arrêté.
Et j'ai tout de suite senti que j'étais pas chaud.
On fait une répétition du mariage.
Je pensais pas que Clarisse serait aussi motivée.
C'est trop ?
Est-ce qu'on est sûr que c'est une bonne idée ?
Quoi ? La pomme ? Dans certaines régions c'est un remède.
Non. Est-ce qu'on s'est pas un peu précipité quoi ?
Vous me donnez la seule dame de votre cour...
Ouais...
Moi je me sens pas de vous la prendre quoi.
Clarisse ? Ouais mais Clarisse on s'en fout, nous se qu'on veut c'est l'alliance.
Oui, mais voilà ! On peut s'allier, on peut grave s'allier !
Mais vous voulez dire s'allier sans mariage ?
Oui !
Ouais mais non, c'est pas équitable du tout là !
Parfait, c'est top ! Moi je suis ravi.
Et maintenant, je voudrais partir...
Vite.
Ok.
Clarisse !
Bonne nouvelle, il y a plus de mariage.
Pourquoi ?
Ah ! Mes chers alliés !
Quelle joie...
D'être...
Et beh... votre allié.
Ça fait 2 fois "allié".
Je suis très honoré... de faire parti... de ce... voilà.
Je suis fier. Ma fierté n'a de sens que cette église.
En chacun de vous, merci.
C'est top ! Merci !
Il est parti ?